Salut ! Toute cette semaine j'étais au café théâtre "La Fontaine d'Argent" à Aix-en-Provence.
J'ai joué là 6 représentations d'affilé, et aujourd'hui on est dimanche il est 17H30, je vais jouer ma dernière représentation !
Oui, je sais tu ne verras pas cette vidéo dimanche, je vais la mettre juste la semaine prochaine. Pour une fois que j'ai un petit décalage.
Alors dans l'équipe en temps normal, il y a Jacques et Fabienne.
Mais ils ne sont pas là, et ben tant pis pour eux !
Jacques et Fabienne c'est ceux qui tiennent ce lieu. Et moi aujourd'hui je suis avec Lorène.
-Coucou.
Lorène de la billetterie.
Et Elisabeth.
-Salut !
Elisabeth tu viens de la billetterie ou...
-Du stage.
D'accord en stage.
Et aussi avec Sylvain, notre régisseur.
-Bonjour !
Je vais essayer une mentalisation mitraillette sur ces trois personnes.
C'est-à-dire que comme je vous ai rencontré toute la semaine, on a discuté un peu tous les jours et tout, je me dis que je suis peu être capable de détecter
quand est-ce que vous mentez ou pas.
Peut être, je ne sais pas.
C'est la première fois dans le Mental Vlog que j'essaie sur trois personnes en même temps.
Je vais vous donner un petit bout de papier.
On va détruire un de mes flyers. Parce qu'il y a des flyers pour ici, et comme c'est la dernière...
Je te donne le "Fabien" Lorène.
Tu le mets dans ta main, là pour l'instant.
Je te donne le "Olicard" pour toi, Elisabeth.
J'ai l'impression de faire des super cadeaux, mais ce ne sont que des bouts de flyers en fait, c'est tout.
[rires]
Et je donne le "Vous mentalise" pour Sylvain.
Je vais me retourner pour ne pas voir ce que vous allez faire, vous allez mettre les mains dans votre dos, et chacun va le placer ou dans sa main droite ou dans sa main gauche.
Ensuite je vais vous poser une question. Vous allez décider de me mentir ou de dire la vérité.
Si vous dites la vérité, pensez à prendre un certain temps pour me répondre, pour ne pas que ce soit trop facile.
Et donc je me tourne. Vous mettez la boulette dans une des deux mains, et vous ne bougez plus.
[dring !]
Tu peux aller décrocher.
Bon, vous avez vu on a eu une petite coupure, mais c'est normal c'était pour une réservation.
Moi je veux bien qu'on coupe vingt fois. [rires]
Vous gardez bien les deux mains, quand c'est fait vous me dites que c'est bon.
-C'est bon !
Alors je me retourne, vous ne bougez plus. Vous avez déterminé individuellement dans votre tête si vous allez dire la vérité ou si vous alliez mentir.
Lorène, est-ce que la boulette est dans ta main droite ?
-Non.
Non. D'accord.
Elisabeth est-ce que la boulette est dans ta main droite ?
-Non.
Sylvain est-ce que la boulette est dans ta main droite ?
-Oui.
Oui ? Ah d'accord...
Je dirai: gauche, droite, gauche, pour moi.
Gauche.
Droite.
Ah ! Je me suis planté ?
-Oui.
Ouvrez vos mains Elisabeth et Lorène.
Ah ! Je me suis juste planté sur Sylvain !
Ah mon dieu !
Ah zut alors !
Ca m'agace ça par contre !
[rires]
Ah la vache !
Mais tu mentais à chaque fois ?
-Oui.
Attends... Mais ça ne marche pas alors...
-Je crois que je me suis trompé au début alors, c'est ça ?
Ah oui tu t'es trompé en fait !
[rires]
-C'était pas volontaire.
On est d'accord. Donc en soi on peut dire que j'ai réussi sur ce coup là.
Il s'est auto mentalisé, parce qu'en fait il s'est auto bluffé, et il ne savait même pas lui même qu'il mentait, et qui mentait pas.
Bon ça va. Donc j'ai réussi.
Et j'ai réussi sur toi.
-Oui.
Et donc je considère que j'ai fait un sans faute, même si tu m'as bien fait flippé !
[rires]
C'est la première fois que j'essaie sur trois personnes en même temps.
Merci pour toute cette semaine, j'étais super bien accueilli.
Et c'est cool.
Et j'espère qu'on se reverra pour roder le nouveau spectacle.
Merci à vous !
Comme quoi vous auriez du aussi venir me voir en spectacle mais il y a d'autres dates de toute manière.
Pensez à vous abonner à la chaine, de mettre un petit pouce en l'air, un commentaire, tout ça, ça fait plaisir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !